[Music]
oh I like this one um salmon and
asparagus that's a favorite mine she's
good as a guy is that a is that a do you
think that's a red flag
I know you're gonna miss me let me take
a look at the
I love it we doing a deep introspect
hey there nice to meet you what's your
name what's your name Lazareth nazarin
like you know like Nazareth Nazareth
yeah like the church like baby Jesus
born in Nazareth yeah Nazarene so I was
named after a church called The Church
of serene so because well you're in
London right now how long you been in
London uh so I was born in London okay
so forever for all forever yeah what do
you think about London like you know I
still like it here I used to hate London
and recently I've changed my mind on it
it's not
um as bad as I always thought it was but
I don't want to raise my kids here
I think there's a lot of
um propaganda and
um it's just not somewhere that I can
see myself raising children
um how do you feel about the United
States
no where do you feel better about
um somewhere
either like in a hot country
um maybe like the Caribbean or something
or
somewhere in Europe like
Switzerland it's interesting somewhere
with loads of green area where we can
like actually set up a life and just
live away from
government rules and everything I want
to be completely self-sufficient and
just like grow my own food have animals
slaughter them
live like that I don't want to live how
I'm living now so you don't care about
marriage
[Laughter]
I care about marriage really yeah so
does that come from a religious place
okay I wouldn't want to marry
um with like a government contract
that's really what my question was yeah
no I don't believe in that I don't
believe the government should have any
saying a man and woman being together I
think I agree I think the contract he
should make with God and that should be
enough to be honest um yeah so yeah I'm
with you no I Vibe with you
do you believe in God I believe in God
correct yes do you go to I don't know I
used to go to cap I was in Catholic
school as a young lad they said in the
UK right lad I was a yeah I was I was um
Catholic School
um we you know went to church but now I
I can't remember the last time I've been
to church to be honest with you I tried
a few different
recently and they just weren't good
found one now which is like completely
awake to everything
um so like
we literally like pray about things like
you know the you know what happened in
the past three years
yes exactly yeah
but yeah I'm not gonna say the word but
we were we pray against all of the stuff
the government were like enforcing on us
they pray for my safety because I do a
lot of speaking out against this I've
had loads of death threats and stuff so
they pray against any evil things coming
towards us
what's your favorite conspiracy theory
favorite conspiracy theory yes what is a
conspiracy theory
um the majority of people lead with a
particular notion about something but
you don't believe it and you think that
there's powers that be a matrix or
something is controlling or puppeteering
what's something that the majority of
people believe in but you think that
there's an underlying lie or a cover-up
that doesn't make sense that you think
is is easy to understand it's as clear
as day and that you often reference
so I'm actually quite well known for
going on a BBC documentary about the
injection that was
forced on us and that's your biggest
okay that's that's that's definitely the
thing that I fight against the most
because it's yeah yeah it's on so so
you're an influencer
I I don't like to call it that but I'm
well known for that well known let's get
into a well-known so your platforms well
I went on a BBC documentary yeah so a
lot of people
saying well they did believe in what I
was saying and they followed me and they
found me and
I think I inspired a lot of people to
speak out against it
um I changed a lot of people's minds on
it very early on and a lot of people are
now thanking me for influencing them to
not go for that decision because they
can now see all of the information
that's coming out about it now I mean
it's been banned for under 50s so it's I
did a lot of speaking out I got
the BBC actually did me very wrong they
edited out all of the stuff that I was
saying all of the stats that I had were
taken out of the final edit that's um
that's a large degree and reason why I
attempt to stay away from platforms like
that because of the editing process I
knew
that would happen but I had
family that I just had to do it because
it was no
it was not out the
information and I'm really glad I did do
it because they ended up believing in
one part which changed a lot of people's
minds where I mentioned some documents
which came out
um and yeah people were just like why
did I find this out from a random 21
year old girl when you know the
government should have been telling me
this information why why am I just
hearing it now
um so yeah I think a lot of people
realized what was going on and changed
their minds because of that so
does body count matter
yeah I think it does
okay but both ways I think it does for
both men and for women
do you think
um body count Matters from men as much
as it matters for women I don't think it
matters as much as it does for women
um purely because of the way that we are
made
um men are you know naturally made to
want to
spray your votes exactly see the Earth
yeah that's a great way of putting it
um whereas women obviously are made to
only be able to carry so y'all listen to
Dr without would y'all classify her as a
pygmy no no I don't think so
biologically we are made different so
like and see that that's what do you
think
I mean like Define a pygmy like I think
people use it as a derogatory term for a
woman who's putting herself to be chosen
by the top men
um otherwise I say you're a pass around
or pass me by so I always say if you a
pick me is in the mind of the woman who
wants to if you're ready to get you want
to get picked so you're gonna put in
your position but people use this
derogatory and I'm like okay pass around
so like is it make her a pick me I think
she's been authentic but I think women
who you know
some women may say that but I don't
think any of us feel like she's like
doing the most to like get his approval
like anything he says she's she's coming
from an authentic life yeah yeah she's
not like oh yeah I like everything you
like yeah I'll move through the U.S like
that's a like a that's like a true pick
me where she's not she's just a robot
and just saying whatever and she's fake
but she I don't think she's fake what'd
you think no I agree I think if anything
I think she's bringing a little bit of
controversy right like it's not like
just so easy asking questions she's like
what is a conspiracy theory right like
she's got a little bit of clap back with
it so I think that's good and engaging
this is a different group of women I'm
sitting with right now because anybody
else like is like oh no oh no she's
being a pigment
okay that's all I want to ask a child
for you know nine months and for that
whole time they're like they can't have
another child whereas men can have as
many as they want to in nine months they
could have like
I don't know you do them that's how many
kids can you have in nine months if you
put work into it yeah I mean I often say
that men have sex with who they can
women have sex with who they want to and
if a man can like there was a video that
just went viral of a young man that has
seven baby mamas
um when and seven different kids and I
don't know if it's like a real story but
he's purporting it like it's real you
know things on the internet sometimes
it's just Cloud Chasers making stuff up
but if it's real
then that's weird but he has the
opportunity availability to be able to
do that whereas a woman it would take
her years to be able to accumulate that
type of rap sheet so exactly yeah um can
I ask you a question you could
absolutely ask me a question did you
submit to any of the
um I got the shot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's like what it is though you see look
at look at her face she's like oh no
she's like I can't I mean she's like
leadership
she was smitting before that okay
how's that make you feel
you think I'm a lemming I didn't think
you're lemming um why did you do it if
you don't mind me asking was it
um the person that I go to for advice
regarding hard decisions in my life is
my father
and he suggested that I do that he comes
from a different era a different
um
um component of life
and I often rely on him for
incredibly hard decisions when it comes
to things like that so
I leveraged
what he was saying and they made the
decision on top of that for myself I'm
I'm My Own man but you know I utilize
mentors in order to kind of you know
come up to the best answer regarding
something and
someone who I
in times of like you know tyranny which
was what happened in the past three
years I understand you you know you
weren't aware of that at the time do you
know now
that what it does to people that was it
I mean it can meme you so injure you to
the point of disability
um it's literally killed
I think 1.8 million is now the count
um they died suddenly after having it
um with no explanation for their death
um so it is now slowly coming out I
think I mean it's been banned for under
50s here
what um how's that number compared to
see the amount of people that took it
how many took it in total
like 500 million or something they were
saying the only
time okay I think the numbers higher
though so I think I have to agree with
Melody at this point you know there are
certain topics that they say are like
this is a drag for the first time
and I just this has become become a
homeschooling session all right this is
so serious bro like
we believe in but like we gotta I mean
it's supposed to be sexy who's like
whose fault is it is it her faults or
his fault for the topic I think he he
dug into it yeah interesting he was
intrigued at first we thought but I feel
like I feel like especially because
she's younger like you know how
passionate will be about something until
we've lived a certain amount of Life had
experiences I remember myself being that
way so it's almost like your identity is
what you do when as you get older you
realize you know like I'm a world of
things or everything I thought was right
or I'm more balanced I'm like more
accepted it's not a criticism but you
can see where an age Gap here it it's
it's it's going to be very difficult I
mean it's nearly how many years is this
16 17. the first the first half of this
I was like
I thought they were gonna I thought it
was going somewhere
yeah and it's like nobody's smiling like
it's like rare it's so serious I feel
tension or like I'm being schooled and
I'm like
like I get it but like we all have
something we're passionate about I can
get into to all types of things but it's
I don't know I don't think you should
leave with that like it just feels very
aggressive he keeps asking her questions
about it he's digging but I feel like I
feel like as women we gotta learn to
deflect better
younger than him like she's just getting
out here you can't really blame her
because that's his fault he has to lead
the date better yeah come on
when he went uh the body count he just
went that way instead of coming back to
the coronavirus yeah there's no flirting
like it's just very serious I felt like
in the beginning there was a bit but
let's let's let's continue I think a lot
of people paid for a fake passport when
people take the flu vaccine how many die
uh not as many yeah I don't know how
many die from the flu vaccine but this
one is different from the others because
it's mRNA technology is it statistically
significantly different than when people
take I mean the scientific makeup of it
is different to any other vaccine so
it's not oops
so the scientific makeup of it is
different to any other injection I can
tell that you're really you're really
passionate about that but as far as men
that you're looking forward in your life
what are the characteristics that you'd
be looking for for mentally strong
um a leader someone who you know can see
any threat around and completely is able
to protect me and our family if we did
have a family which is what I want so
um someone who is Godly who understands
that you know God provides and who prays
I'd like my dream is to have someone who
just prays with me
um every day about anything we're going
through because I do feel that God can
bring you through
difficult situations if you just depend
on him for
help and guidance
that makes a lot of sense yeah so so
what do you think are the things that
you'd be willing to contribute to a man
um obviously I do have quite Traditional
Values
um I do believe that the woman should
stay at home once you have kids to look
after the kids to you know raise the
children with your values
um because I feel if you depend on other
people to raise your children it does
cause problems you know they they're
learning someone else's values instead
of your own and right now there's so
much propaganda going around in schools
and stuff and I would want to homeschool
my children for that reason because I
don't believe that
schools are a safe place for kids to
learn anymore
interesting yeah they say that the
mother passes down the culture from
generations to generation so what else
is there anything else that you think
you'd be able to lend to a man like
um I'm very clean I cook
um a lot what's the last thing you call
the last thing I cooked is a roast
dinner oh no actually a steak
steak dinner steak this morning how'd
you cook that steak
um was it medium no it was well probably
rare rare
oh did you kill the calf yourself
no apparently I didn't I'm not at that
level yet that's my dream is to get
there kill it eat it boom Hey listen I
respect it I ain't mad at it what's your
name one more time Nazarene pleasure to
me it's a little bit cold yeah we got
we're gonna give you an iron tablet out
in the front an iron tablet well I don't
need it I got there's a steak in my diet
so no iron needed of course we don't
want to give you any medicines or
nothing like that you know what I mean
yeah
I'll be honest I don't think that she's
looking for a man I think she she came
up here pushing an agenda I got I got
nothing to do with this goddamn I
don't I don't I don't know what the what
was that who are y'all bringing up here
for me
blessing top producer what y'all
bringing up here for me what was that
what was that what was that
I'm out of here y'all don't care for me
what was that
and she want me to she want me to
kill him and cut up little Bassey the
calf and eat it if I can't do that
I'm a modern man all right give me a
supermarket give me the cut of meat I
don't listen I'm a YouTuber I gotta make
time to make content baby girl
content I don't got time to be Mr
Wilderness it's not what I'm about what
I look at the scientists to see what the
goddamn to happen and go along what
Jesus
refill
wait a minute yeah
guys listen to me there's so many more
questions that I that I need to ask
foreign